(upbeat music)
- One of the newest ways of
thinking about problem solving
for me is something that my
math professor would tell me.
He would say don't be afraid to be stuck.
And I think that a lot of the time
when we are doing math and we get stuck,
it's like sometimes
you can feel like, wow,
this is a reflection of me
and my mathematical abilities.
Maybe I shouldn't be doing math.
But really a lot of the time
it's just an indication
that you need to spend more
time doing the math or figuring out
what the problem is exactly.
If you haven't gotten
stuck yet, then I mean,
you probably will get stuck at some point.
So being stuck is just a part of math
and it's kind of learning what to do when
you are stuck is a really
big part of being creative
in math and being able to
solve problems in the future.
- One example that I often
use is I often try to
solve problems both in the
traditional algebraic way
but I also try to visualize problems
in 2D and 3D space to
solve them more visually.
And so I think the more ways
that you can figure out
how to solve a problem,
the more ways that you can eventually
save in your toolbox and use later on
to solve other problems.
- There's lots of different
tools and resources
like apps and puzzle games
that are gonna help you
think about problems in new ways
and help develop that
critical thinking that you
need to be able to apply your skills
to a lot of different areas.
And sometimes even starting
at the answer and working backwards
through the problem can
help you see a different way
of getting to the answer.
- Students can combine new ways
of thinking about problem solving
by trying to look at it
from different angles.
Anytime you approach a problem
if you're just looking at
it from your perspective,
you're not gonna get a holistic
view of the solution space.
So try to have perspectives
and look at the problem
from multiple angles to understand
all the ways in which it could be viewed.
The more holistically you view a problem,
the more paths you look at,
the more efficient and effective
you're gonna be at solving it.